ne laisse pas ce chien pisser sur mon
allée il n'a aucune idée de qui s'en sort aussi
bien c'était l'un d'entre vous
faire ça bien c'était l'un de vous
sortez d'ici
oh mon Dieu donnez moi les clés bonjour bonjour
quel est ton nom Otto Otto
Otto je suis Abby oh TTL
[Musique]
je suis désolé que tu m'ai eu plus tôt
j'ai amené de nouveaux voisins  vous de la nourriture d'
accord au revoir
êtes-vous toujours aussi hostile Je ne suis pas
hostile d'accord vous n'êtes pas chaque mot que
vous dites est comme un câlin chaleureux
[Musique]
vous avez raison je n'ai pas de permis vous
n'avez pas de permis de conduire  quel
âge as-tu
[Musique]
comment es-tu arrivé ici
tu ne prends pas mon lit
Je me demandais si tu pouvais nous aider
Je ne suis pas sûr de ça ça va être
très amusant
comment as-tu fait du bon travail toi  devrais
te tapoter dans le dos
[Musique]
J'ai un chat
pour tout faire par toi-même devine quoi
dire pourrais-je emprunter une pièce de monnaie qu'as-tu
fait c'était al  l la faute du Clown
[Musique]